jean pierre coffe est un comédien doublé
d'un homme de goût il met en scène cette
double vocation avec le brio qu'on lui
connaît à la télévision et dans ses
livres au bonheur des fruits qu'ils
publient chez balland n'est pas
seulement un appétissant recueil de
recettes sucrées
c'est un volume substantiel c'est à dire
plein de substance et de digressions
savoureuses sur les confitures et les
compotes la pâtisserie et les friandises
il n'y a que lui il faut en convenir
pour vous inciter péremptoirement en
préambule à confiture est heureux et
libres en oubliant ses aberrations que
sont à ses yeux les confitures moins
sucré négation même de l'objet en
question la confiture post il d'emblée
c'est 65 % de sucre après avoir rappelé
comment on transforme un trombone en
desnoyers auteurs évoqué la fonction
épilatoire du caramel dans l'antiquité
il en vient aux fruits qu'il décrit
comme s'il s'agissait de véritables
personnages l'ananas et la banane ont en
commun une vie sexuelle des plus
décevantes
la fraise doit beaucoup à un agronome
voyageurs nommé cela ne s'invente pas
fraisiers et la groseille en jeu les
filets des listes d'alfred hitchcock
réapprenons l'art de la tartine et de la
marmelade à vous à nous ces délices que
sont le choc n'est d'orange de pommes et
de citron la soupe de fruits rouges ou
les fruits déguisés
ces 600 pages un régal évidemment